what is the blue metric
for many nlp tasks we can use common
metrics like accuracy or f1 score but
what do you do when you want to measure
the quality of a text that's been
translated from a model in this video
we'll take a look at a widely used
metric for machine translation called
blue
the basic idea behind blue is to assign
a single numerical score to a
translation that tells us how good it is
compared to one or more reference
translations
in this example we have a word in
spanish that has been translated into
english by some model
if we compare the generated translation
to some reference human translations we
can see that the model is actually
pretty good but has made a common error
the spanish word tengo means have in
english and this one-to-one translation
is not quite natural
so how can we measure the quality of a
generated translation in some automatic
way
the approach that blue takes is to
compare the n-grams of the generator
translation to the n-grams of the
references
now an engram is just a fancy way of
saying a chunk of n-words so let's start
with unigrams which corresponds to the
individual words in a sentence
in this example you can see that four of
the words in the generator translation
are also found in one of the reference
translations
and once we've found our matches one way
to assign a score to the translation is
to compute the precision of the unigrams
this means we just count the number of
matching words in the generated and
reference translations and normalize the
count by dividing by the number of words
in the generation
in this example we found four matching
words and a generation has five words
now in general precision ranges from
zero to 1 and higher precision scores
mean a better translation
but this isn't really the whole story
because one problem with unigram
precision is that translation models
sometimes get stuck in repetitive
patterns and just repeat the same word
several times
if we just count the number of word
matches we can get really high precision
scores even though the translation is
terrible from a human perspective
for example if a model just generates
the word six we get a perfect unigram
precision score
so to handle this blue uses a modified
precision that clips the number of times
to count a word based on the maximum
number of times it appears in the
reference translation
in this example the word six only
appears once in the reference so we clip
the numerator to one and the modified
unigram precision now gives a much lower
score as expected
another problem with unigram precision
is that it doesn't really take into
account the order in which the words
appear in the translations
for example suppose we had yoda
translate a spanish sentence then we
might get something completely backwards
like years 60 30 have i
in this case the modified unigram
precision gives a high precision which
is not really what we want
so to deal with word ordering problems
blue actually computes the precision for
several different engrams and then
averages the result
for example if we compare four grams we
can see that there are no matching
chunks of four words in the translations
and so the foreground precision is zero
now to compute blue scores in the
datasets library is really very simple
you just use the load metric function
provide your model's predictions with
their references and you're good to go
the output will contain several fields
of interest
the precision field contains all the
individual precision scores for each
engram
the blue score itself is then calculated
by taking the geometric mean of the
precision scores
and by default the mean of all four
n-gram precisions is reported a metric
that is sometimes called blue four
in this example we can see that the blue
score is zero because the foreground
precision was zero
now the blue metric has some nice
properties but it is far from a perfect
metric
the good properties are that it's easy
to compute and it's widely used in
research so you can compare your model
against others on common benchmarks
on the other hand there are several big
problems with blue including the fact it
doesn't incorporate semantics and it
struggles a lot on non-english languages
another problem with blue is that it
assumes that the human translations have
already been tokenized and this makes it
hard to compare models that use
different tokenizers
so as we've seen measuring the quality
of text is still a difficult and open
problem in nlp research for machine
translation the current recommendation
is to use the sacral blue metric which
addresses the tokenization limitations
of blue
as you can see in this example computing
the sacred blue score is almost
identical to the blue one the main
difference is that we now pass a list of
texts instead of a list of words to the
translations and sakura blue takes care
of the tokenization under the hood